Okay, so Michael wanted to have a quiz here,
'because Michael again, likes those sort of things and, and
I like to please Michael. So, we came up
with three possibilities, one of which we hope is right.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I've labeled them here in orange, A, B,
and C and put little radio boxes next to 'em, so
you could select 'em. So which of those three hypotheses
are, is a good one to pick next? So, A is
a horizontal line that says everything above it should be a plus. B is a,
another horizontal line that says everything above it should be a plus. And C is
a vertical line, like the last two
hypotheses that we found, that says everything to
the left should be a plus. So, which do you think is the right one? Go.